hi guys it's silverette again and
welcome to another episode of the Silver
City let's play now in this episode I'm
going to make three skyscrapers and
since I got a lot of feedback on my um
well the idea of whether I should do
time lapses with commentary or time
lapses with music or no time lapses at
all or more Skype stuff I got many mixed
reviews but I also got some people
saying that I should actually do more
time lapses with music now since I'm
actually only going to build the three
skyscrapers in this episode and I don't
really have that much to talk about I'm
just going to let the music play for a
bit in this episode so
enjoy
you are sure to cause a wreckage cuz
you've got the damn full
package
full
from far away they came to
on with
knowledge they Chang the world and left
us without
warning they will return the day when
they are
need again it
shifted
up through the
sky
a
we pray for knowledge
for
the time has come to find what we
w
nah
a
aahah
as I wake up every
morning I wish the day would
end because a day without you would my
life I don't know me and I was like
uhoh oh you were
like noou noou I was
like oh you were
like no no come on let's rewind a
smile that look upon your face my heart
is empty and
unguided I'm blind leading
Chase got I had a
plan a plan with you and
me was it feeling of my own dreams
breaking me down to my
knees
I cry at the be wondering if I'll be
okay my head is it's tell me nothing
it's got nothing left to say and I was
likeoh you were
like no no I was
like oh oh oh you were
like no oh no come on let till a
smile that look upon your face my heart
is in the and
unguided I'm blind leading
Chase thought I had a
plan a plan with you and
me was theing of my own dreams breaking
me down to my
knees
oh
he
hey
yeah
oh
fire the rail
gun fire
yeah
w
fire the rail gun
a